for me it was always about the work i
really you know
i really loved it
and i wish i could have done it more
but
i didn't
how long have you been in los angeles 22
years
and in a couple of months a month a
couple months
i'm leaving forever
not by choice but uh some family members
need some help and my wife and i are
going to be that help so
i'm leaving los angeles the place i've
lived the longest actually
my whole life so how does that feel to
you do you
is it sort of like you're seeing those
years flip by in your mind like a tv
show like it's
i is a combination
of uh regret
and uh i think kind of the realization
that
maybe things not working out for me in
the entertainment industry maybe was for
the best
uh because i think the timing of how
[Music]
if i if the success came the way i
thought it was going to come
at the time that i thought it was going
to come
[Music]
when spec sales were huge and
people made money fast um
uh i guess
i i feel like i've just gone through
like the longest training program
anybody could ever go through to learn
how to do a bunch of [ __ ]
i didn't know how to direct or
write or act or do stand-up
the way i do now from having done it
sitting down to write a book having
done all these different things made the
writing
easier and better and and all that stuff
because i've been doing it
um i
you know i i wanted to come here and be
successful and buy my wife a house
didn't happen so
when things don't work out the way you
want then you
improvise adapt and overcome and that's
what i'm going to do moving to albany
new york which is not
a entertainment capital that i know of
[Music]
but locations will be easier to get
i do have a line on actors play shorts
is something i can continue doing
graphic novel has i don't know how many
more issues
in it
i guess i had a lot of fun
i met a lot of people uh
some of it was not fun
but uh i guess overall
i wouldn't have done it any other way
because i had to know like i had to know
what was going to happen you said
regrets earlier
oh yeah what were the regrets oh god
too many to number uh
i guess i should have tolerated some
fools more
and
[Music]
yeah a bunch of stuff
but aren't you glad that forgive me i
don't know where you were before you
went to boston
yeah okay but were you still in what if
you had stayed in upstate new york
and or gone back i don't know you know
what
your travel line was and you worked for
a company
and they pushed you out the door because
they're hiring people from oh sure
somewhere else or they're closing that
plant or something
so that essentially happened to the
company uh that i
was working for in boston i was very
lucky that
the company i had a day job with in
boston had a company out here
so when i i said i'm moving to los
angeles if you guys want me that's where
i'm going to be and they were like
you can work in the other company's
office for boston so i had a job
that i flew with so that was great
um and then they pulled the plug on the
company fired everybody
once i got out here
but what was the question
so i guess the question is what if you
hadn't come here
wouldn't you be more regretful for had
not because you're you're still with
your wife oh yeah i'm not trying to get
too personal but i mean
some people don't oh yeah every time all
the time you know what i'm saying i'm
i know people have died you know
in pursuit of this uh some people died
from suicide
some people died from drugs overdose
some people died from
lifestyle you might say and
uh i
guess i guess what i
didn't know and there's no way you
really could know
like i did stuff in boston and
it you know was done live there's no you
know this video of it but
most of the time it was like it was
theater it was something that was done
for a live audience and that's what it
was meant
to do and then when it was over it ended
and that was it
it didn't exist anymore except for in
the minds of the people who saw it
i've heard from people who remember the
stuff i did in the 90s
when i was in boston performance art
stuff installation
art and like all that stuff is gone none
of it
exists anymore but they remember it
and you know if you
make a movie and it's successful and a
lot of people see it and they'll
remember it sometimes movies become
a part of people's lives they buy the
dvd they watch it on a regular basis
it's something on the background it's
the movie they go to when they're
feeling shitty
that is uh
something i sort of got to experience
with vampire mob that
you know i did have people contact me
who said that they
you know life wasn't great and they were
kind of down and
they enjoyed the humor and the
characters and the story in it
and it gave them some place to go for a
while and that's
why i feel like to some degree
storytelling is a service
you are in service of other people
stories are for other people and
that's who you're creating for
i mean you could create for yourself but
if they don't see it then it doesn't
exist
what do you think that you should have
tried more of or maybe
maybe there's nothing you know
i changed directions a bunch of times uh
when things weren't going right i'm like
you know when things with acting and
stand up weren't going great
and i was looking at writing
screenwriting and i hadn't written
anything and i'm like
man do i have a learning curve and i'm
like i gotta back up everything else
take classes really focus on
on screenwriting and and learn
everything that i can about it and i've
lost the question again
um what what do you think that maybe you
should have tried
i guess
i probably should have um
um i think i should have kept doing
stand-up
i think i could have should have kept
spreading myself out then
the way i was and find
uh finding ways to deal with that
chaos which i enjoyed to some degree
um but the more
i met a lot more people doing stand-up
um
and when you're a writer you meet less
people because you're at home writing
and i was in a few writer's groups and
there were always a nightmare i
just it was almost like competitive
notes like
oh yeah you didn't like my screenplay
wait till i give you notes on yours it
was
garbage i remember one screenplay
that this guy wrote and had very
specific terminology
to the x games to all these special
things you do on a skateboard on a bmx
bike and all this stuff
and i'm reading it and i'm like yeah i
don't know what any of this is and he's
like well that's the language that they
use that's the thing i'm like yeah but
what does that mean what does they what
do they do
well all you have to do is say that and
people know what it is yeah but the
person at the
reading the at the studio the agent
they're not gonna know this
oh i'm sorry i'm telling you information
you don't want to hear
i can oh so this isn't feedback you just
want to be
you want you just want to be told this
is good you don't want to make it better
you just want to so then and then when
it was time for my
my screenplay to be read he just was
like anything he could find
and and you you know i know what good
feedback is and what is not good
feedback and that was
revenge feedback
what advice would you give to someone
else leaving los angeles
hmm i wouldn't
give them any advice i guess uh
yeah i kind of uh
sometimes advice is uh
just someone else's version of the way
they think things should work
and and it's just uh uh
it's just another obstacle it's just
it's a
it's a your expectation is being managed
by someone else's experience
and their experience isn't necessarily
what's going to be your experience so
the advice has no value
because they're well the way i did it
well yeah
the way you did it is and and that was i
think
one of my problems was that i was trying
to i saw how other people made it and i
was trying to do it the way they did it
i was okay so you do this and then you
win a contest and then you get a manager
and then you go out take a script out
and then you sell it
and uh
there's a million ways careers happen
and don't
make the mistake i did of sort of
telling your story you're
like well this is gonna happen then i'm
gonna do this this and this and this and
that's the way it's gonna be
and then when it's not oh i did
something wrong
i guess i'm the problem so i gotta
change the plan
so i'm not gonna do this this and this
and all right that's not working
i'm gonna it
i i enjoyed less of it
missed out on a lot
because i was working so hard
to try to make it what did you miss out
on
oh birthdays vacations
seeing the outside world friendships
a lot a lot
you can only sit in one chair at a time
what does success look like to you
i don't know anymore actually
that is a good question
nothing to do with the entertainment
industry
no
well you'll still be able to make
stories oh yeah and and now you might
have a pool of people
that oh sure aren't going to be you know
there's going to be access to
talent up there as well yeah and maybe
something new will come from it and
it'll be a new definition of
because i think coming being here we're
so clouded by
not the middle class version of success
oh yeah but this like
astronomical thing that i don't even
know if those people are happy we don't
know that
we don't know if that's i have met a lot
of people who were
wealthy and successful and miserable i
remember talking to somebody who had
they were working on a basic cable show
and a network show at the same time
and they were complaining that the basic
cable show didn't send a driver
and then the network show did it was you
know why doesn't the basic cable show
sit in the driver and i was just like
i'm in the back of my mind going you
know how many [ __ ] people would like
to have that [ __ ] problem
not having the basic cable show send a
driver oh you have to drive yourself to
your job that you get poor you
you're breaking my heart it's like
listen to people who like social media
experts who complain about traveling
they're like oh my god it's so hard to
travel from conference to conference and
miss flights and all the rest but really
get up on a roof and do some roofing in
august and los angeles
get the smell of tar up in your nose and
then tell me how hard it is again to sit
in an airport
really is it really that hard to sit in
an airport sorry
sorry you have to sit so long sorry
that's such hard work for you
sorry you're not at the hotel where
you're supposed to be at the right time
again get on a [ __ ] roof in [ __ ]
august with the smell of tar in your
nose
and tell me again how hard it is that
you work
writing's not hard none of this [ __ ] is
hard
none of this [ __ ] is roofing in august
in los angeles anytime you think you're
working hard
think oh well you know what i'm not on a
roof in 95 degrees
with tar up my nose that's hard work
all the rest of this you know i worked
hard but i didn't do roofing for the
last 22 years
you know i was indoors
it was not hard work i've seen artwork
i've been about hard work i've done hard
work
none of this [ __ ] is hard work hard work
is a bunch of 18-hour days on set day
after day after day that is hard work
hard work gaffers do hard work
electricians do hard work harvard just
do hard work
actors less so director's less so
so i never wanted to be a video village
director i never wanted to be the guy
sitting looking at [ __ ] monitors and
barking [ __ ] from
a chair i wanted to be holding a camera
and i wanted to be
right in there with the actors because
that's where
it is happening and if i didn't know how
to run a camera then i couldn't have
done that so i learned how to run a
camera so i can do that
and i'm a better director because i run
camera
because i'm there i'm with the actor the
actor's looking at me the director who's
operating the camera that's pointing at
them
completely different experience than the
guy over in the corner
who's barking stuff back or gets up
walks over says something walks back
i just yell cut good anything all right
again go
i can shoot 10 pages in four hours door
to door in and out done it every time
every episode of play shorts was four
hours
rehearse the actors for two hours a week
before
bring them in we walk into knicks at
four o'clock
we set up lights we eat dinner we
shoot we close it up 9 9 30 we're gone
four or five hours all you need
don't eat an 18-hour day and you don't
need a giant crew
any thoughts on um friendships in la
partnerships
friendships in l.a are
sometimes friendships are based on
projects there's a lot of project
friendships like you work on a project
and everybody's
friends and you can know each other
forever and then the project ends you
never see each other again
uh that's pretty common and then you're
right it's like
co-worker friendships it's that kind of
thing
[Music]
i think it is harder to have or at least
it was i found it harder to
[Music]
have more meaningful friendships
just at the
the pace of everything that was going
and
everyone's so worried about their career
and and who's got what who's doing what
and the next thing that it
it um didn't allow for a lot of uh
um deeper friendships
i felt but some of that's me
so and some of that delay
so is it about the work for me it was
always about the work i really
you know i really loved it
and i wish i could have done it more
but
i didn't
what's the thing you're most proud of
the thing i'm most proud of
nothing that's on screen i don't think
i'm
i think i'm more proud of what i
what i knew
that i got through it
i guess not any specific work it's sort
of the
all of it my
all those classes
workshops writers groups and meetings
with managers and contests oh
christ
i could have made a lot more money doing
something else
but it wasn't i moved out of here for
the money because i was doing
you know the non-profit art thing in
boston
and there's something about
the
there's something about making art
when you know it's not going to make you
any money
that is different when
you know i mean people oh i paint and i
put up in a gallery and people pay me
thousands of dollars yeah
most painters don't have that most
painters are
they got a lot of paintings and that
haven't sold
and i think
when did an installation that had
uh 27 tvs in it and
things were run by motion detectors and
there were vcrs and slide projectors and
took up a giant room and
it took me 50 hours to put it up and i
had help
and i was in that gallery for a week and
almost slept on the floor one night it
was there so long
and i knew i wasn't gonna make a dime
from it knew it
knew it cost me money to do it knew i
wasn't gonna make a dime
but i had to do it i had to do it i had
to make it
i it was the first thing i ever made it
was
huge and
uh i showed it once
i never showed it again and
that thing changed everything if i
didn't do that thing i wouldn't be
sitting here talking to you right now
because i know the dominoes that went
over
because of that one thing i made
so
when you make something
[Music]
that is for commerce that is that is the
goal
commerce is the goal and it doesn't sell
then it's not a success
and and that is it's a business
that is people don't get paid if you
don't make money
uh art is you know i got grants i got
you know work to day jobs to pay for all
the stuff so i could have the time to
make the art um
and all the and the the reward was
seeing people go through it hearing
from people afterwards like that was
enough
and
when i started doing stand-up and
performance art
and dealing with doing a little bit of
touring
with a [ __ ] with two different shows um
i that's when you know i got things got
to get paid for
you know i got to pay for all this stuff
so this has to make at least this much
money to pay for this much stuff and if
i'm going to get
in if i'm going to get paid it's going
to be above these costs
they when you're out here in los angeles
in the entertainment industry
you're not making anything that is not
made for money
um that is the goal that's it's a
business you're not making art
you're making commerce you're making
product
and yes there's some creativity in it
but if nobody wants it
nobody wants nobody cares well you've
written a great screenplay that no one
will ever make that no one wants
there's lots of people who have i've
done definitely done a couple of those
but uh so the value of it
is like screenplays are not
to be read they're maps for movies if
they're not made into movies then
they're not
then they don't exist they're nothing
they're not there's some screenplays
literature there's people sitting around
hey we had a good screenplay yesterday
it's so good
that's ridiculous um
but
the i think the thing with the internet
neighbors
who have a response to my work is
similar to seeing human beings have a
response to my work in a gallery
and i started as a photographer so it
was just
a picture on a wall or in front of them
or in a newspaper magazine and then when
it was installation
i surrounded the viewer sound
light images physical objects
um a structure that changed the space
and then i started doing performance art
because the same thing i could control
i they were sitting there i was sitting
here and i could
create something that we could all that
could have we could
it could happen together and
you would experience it your way and and
i'm and we're all here together
this is what's happening and yeah you
paid a ticket
to get in here but it's barely going to
cover the cost of doing this [ __ ]
show
uh that
is very similar to when i make shorts
and i put them online and i hear from
people who
who saw them it's the value
[Music]
value is the experience that you're
creating for someone else in whatever
media
so you know stand-up comedy your job is
to make people laugh
so that's your job if you're telling
somebody a story
it's a funny story not a funny story it
has to keep them
amused and engaged and interested and
when it's uh art
i think you don't think exactly the same
way
i think it's i think it is a little more
of the uh i'm making art and you're
gonna
see it and
the relationships i think different a
little bit
yeah see or just thinking of like cindy
sherman
you know and and whether i mean i know
she got a lot of criticism for some of
the work that she did but i just found
her so fascinating
yeah yeah just just especially the time
in history that she was doing
her work compared to now when everyone's
taking selfies left and right
right right such a weird and also just
the reality that people
are more comfortable in front of lenses
there's going to be entire generations
now that have no problem being in front
of the camera
or just living for life in front of the
camera not even being able to enjoy an
event
having to show having to document it yep
selfie museums and that's all cool
that's great
but at some point you're not really in
reality though
right people are going to movies and
they're texting during the movie
why would you pay for a ticket is it for
the air conditioning and somewhere to
sit right
and that and and and that's what makes
going to the movies unattractive to
people
like it has to be marvel it has to be
loud in
action so everyone's attention is on
screen and not on the other screen they
have in their pocket
and if the movie's not good enough to
keep your attention from texting
then maybe it's not moving
or maybe
we need more it's like a drug and so
what it's not enough to just have good
dialogue anymore
a great interesting scene between two
people we've become too desensitized to
it
well i don't know if all of us have but
i think they're definitely
you know there's it's like pop music pop
music is inherently shitty music
not all of it but a lot of it except for
the song pop music that's actually good
so pop music is you know it's
it's uh it's short it's
catchy it's got some part that you can
sing along with or come along with or
whatever it's got some little
chorus hook thing in it someone's been
jilted yeah exactly
and i think it's i think it's the same
to some degree
with with movies uh that are popular is
that you know
it's just meant as this little thing
that you see and it comes and goes and
and that's it it's very and then there's
other movies that maybe have a bigger
impact um i don't
know i really think about the audience
audiences now so many people are
watching stuff alone
you know with a laptop or on their phone
or you know
if you're on a plane everyone's watching
a movie
on something and that is the more normal
behavior now than
to have the sort of communal experience
at a theater where you're
you're all laughing at once or you're
all jumping at once and now it's just
you
and i think as a storyteller i
like now i never think about a theater i
never think about a group of people
watching i always think about one person
yeah i never think about a group i used
to think about groups of people when i
was writing and now i think about one
person
especially writing the book i definitely
think about one person because that is
the only way it works
but even with yeah even with the other
stuff i would say that's true